you have this look you have this iconic
look that people have it long before
Breaking Bad there were people that you
know you've got this look that the
character Wreckers dreamed like dream of
having a face like this that captures so
much they do you know some people just
call it ugly what I'm saying you've had
people suggest to you oh we could nip
here we could tuck there and you right
oh yeah yeah a plastic surgeon said to
me said you know we can we can raise
those eyelids we can open or lower them
whatever open your eyes
and I went do I've made some money with
these eyes don't mess with it yeah don't
mess the success we have a picture of
one fan who's such a fan of yours she
made a cake of you look at that isn't
that amazing
that's a cake how was it did you taste
it yeah what's it Natalie about yes sir
side serve Natalie side serve and I did
I ever taste it no and I also never said
thank you to her so Natalie thank you
very much for making a cake yeah
[Laughter]
I can imagine wheeling that out for a
kid's party yeah yeah [ __ ] jerk
you